for me you know when I was an artist a
lot of what I did was collage I would
bring together disparate elements and
then when they be when they got side by
side there was a kind of magical child
born from those disparate elements and
that's my creative process so I'll bring
in some music maybe unexpected music and
I'll bring in some readings I might take
five books and just randomly open to
different pages I might go for a walk
and when these things are placed side by
side interestingly enough in the best of
circumstances there's a magical child
and that's my creative process is
collage it's like being immersed in life
rather than separating yourself a person
that I look to for inspiration
definitely Sharon Gannon Oh Sharon has
the the prime mover of gville of de yoga
it was her her her magical child she
motivates me on a daily basis with her
her high hopes and her her optimism I
tend to be a little bit pessimistic and
I get mired in that a little bit uh
what's the use and Sharon always brings
me back to well what are you going to do
right now in the next few minutes what
could you do to make the world a better
place and and she's constantly filled
with new ideas and new possibilities and
new projects so many projects I have to
run to keep up
you